what's going on you guys gaming addict
here lord addict we're going to do a an
interview
uh you know you guys know i've been
doing these a little bit more here
lately i want to bring more coverage to
the industry on uh you know titles that
you know
i would say is isn't is in
corners of the market that you know
isn't played as much i do feel like turn
base uh it's slept on like hardly slept
on and i feel like you know i want to
bring it up man i want to lift it high
so we're going to be interviewing two of
the devs off of phantom brigade uh
obviously i got petey here from uh the
iron lords podcast uh you know he does a
lot of good work over there on the lords
of gaming.net uh first off i would
really you know let's get a little bit
background from
addie uh we got addie in i'm sorry i
don't want to butcher your name again
nikita nikita adeline nikita so
give me brief you know summary where you
guys have uh came from uh because i
didn't notice that when you know i
definitely went over there and i looked
a little bit on uh
you know
any outlets that i could see on you know
where the history you guys that came
from you know what are other titles in
this industry that you guys have worked
on before fan brigade
you wanna you wanna go or
sure i can go first um
pretty much um
so i'm relatively new to the industry
but
i worked on at sega for a bit and also
on some other uh projects mostly on
strategy games like motorsports manager
or
total war stuff
as well and then
moved to vancouver to work on phantom
brigade
oh the yeah i did see when i was looking
up but it looked like you used to be in
the qa of sega i think that's what it's
so
it's interesting i i really that that's
cool what about you ad what's stuff that
you've done in the past
yeah so um
been working here at brace yourself
games for many years now and working on
phantom brigade of course
and previously before that i worked
on universe 10 box 2
and kerbal space program and then a
bunch of other ones that are various nda
contracts and stuff i've worked on
over the years and been in the industry
for quite a while now
that's good we got we got us a vet here
man we got us
you know i've always went
in the standpoint where i do feel like
people don't give developers enough
credit like obviously we can only go off
what we know a lot of people don't
really know how what goes into the
process of making a game and it's a very
time consuming process and i feel like
people expect like they snap their
fingers and it just works uh you know it
that's why i always try to like give
back to the developer community because
i do feel like you guys aren't respected
enough in certain to a certain degree
not like obviously
it's not entirely the consumer's fault
like i said because usually when it
comes to like a game being buggy or
something they they they like to
automatically go on the hunt but it's
just like you these guys
they they're people man they they got
lives you know they they they got
feelings too i really you know i
appreciate you guys coming through here
you know one thing i want to you know go
into uh phantom brigade i got a pretty
good selection of questions here and i'm
sure petey got his own little questions
uh but first thing i want to really talk
about is like what was the inspirations
for phantom brigade was there any
particular games that like you know
inspired you guys to make this type of
great space game
yeah and one of the biggest inspirations
was french mission
specifically the older front mission
series like prime mission three and four
and also front mission five which was
not really released in the west
uh aside from that
uh the
you know mech warrior and then
battletech
the tabletop version because when we
started it battletech
hadn't had a game come out you know they
weren't working on the airplane scheme
ones at the time
uh and then also just mecha anime in
general specifically like 8th ms team i
think was one of the biggest sources of
inspiration because those were
those were gundam that they were more of
the real robot genre more grounded you
know urban fighting and not
flying around in in space with you know
wings and sights and stuff like that
nothing wrong with that that's super
cool too but not quite what we were
going for
yeah i actually felt like you guys chose
mech it really helps the game because
there's a lot of different types of
strategy games out there and there's a
lot of mech games too but for some
reason when people make mech games they
just gravitate towards i don't know
maybe it's like you know you got stuff
like pacific rim that's made that type
of niche thing more popular uh maybe
even to some point like transformers and
zoids and stuff back in the day so it's
always been present
so i i always get i like the
customization you guys have in the game
like i like the fact that you can
individually color stuff uh you know
was that a huge focus when you guys were
going into that type of stuff to make
sure that you know uh with games like
xcom where you can name people you can
uh you know have a real sense of uh you
know value to some of these characters
was that customization really important
yeah that's actually been one of our
core design pillars ever since we
started the game
like customization and that goes all the
way down into modding as well so the
game is designed very much since it is
single player to be something that can
be your own experience and to enjoy it
as you like
and that includes you know naming your
pilots naming your mechs doing
deliveries customization
uh all the parts
yeah there is a lot of in general very
small modular parts that allow players
to pretty much do whatever they want
with their macs
starting from
sweet like
changing the color of a forearm to
as i said like renaming your pilots and
really making them stand out to be your
team
of pilots and mechs uh that you take
through the your story uh the one thing
i wanted to mention as well is you kind
of called into this into attention a
little bit earlier
that um like pacific rim and
you know battle tech and a lot of games
are super giant mechs they're like the
supermax
that are as big as a building
and there is another kind of like sub
genre of mechs that are more like
fighter jets and the
vande brigade ones are definitely under
that category they're very fast they're
very agile and they're only about two
stories tall they're about seven eight
meters
um so they're very much
almost like
upgraded power armor
yeah yeah they're more like exoskeletons
than they are you know towering walking
buildings and stuff that you would see
in in other media
when you when you kind of like since
you're talking about this now um when
you were deciding to
build a game based on these exoskeletons
and them being interchangeable parts and
and thinking
of you know that type of
uh of that gameplay uh when you
you know um for you know when you're
going through the game and you have to
like
like make uh well i should say make your
mechs
through your combat systems or crafting
them in your you know in your mobile
base like
did you is that the way that you wanted
that to be created to like find you know
more improved like your your weaponry or
did you want to look like is that what
the only ways that you can kind of do
that or is it just you know you can find
like you know super weapons through like
questing and things like things like
that
[Music]
or mission or mission or mission uh or
should say like mission completions and
things like that i i think like if i'm
understanding the question right one of
our goals was that the
thematically you know you're sort of
underdogs and you're doing a lot of
scavenging
so your primary method of getting gear
is capturing equipment from the enemy so
it's inherently
asymmetric in that regard so you're
doing a lot of salvaging uh you get to
see the enemies have a cool weapon and
then you're kind of incentivized to make
the enemy eject and be able to capture
their gear so we do have rewards we're
going after things like
weapons caches and convoys that are
protected trying to raid them but that's
kind of the core
driving design force between how you get
your gear
yeah and then generally building on that
there's quite a few ways of getting that
equipment usually the enemies will
provide equipment that's higher level
than yours but as i said there are cone
ways that you can rate you can craft
your own equipment based on how far you
are in the campaign uh different
missions provide you with equipment and
you can always loot them off the enemy
depending on how well
uh you preserve those parts during
combat where if an arm gets destroyed
it's much more expensive to salvage it
versus something that you keep intact
where you force the pilot to eject let's
say from their neck
well full full disclaimer coming from me
when we came back from pax um i spoke to
your pr rep and they were able to give
me a key and i ended up playing
literally sitting down playing it one
night and next thing i know like eight
hours passed and i was like what am i
doing here i have to go to bed and there
was a lot of different aspects of it
that i thought was very interesting
and that that
kind of scavenging for your your
mechs and your materials was one of the
things that kind of drew me to wanting
to keep playing because i wanted to keep
you know uh
making my
team stronger
and you know grow the way that you you
know grow how many mechs you have
and you know in your uh your convoy um
and so on and so forth i thought it was
very interesting is there is there a
reason why you kind of um
set only like a certain amount of
resource gathering uh towards the end of
each combat battle
oh you're talking about the salvage
budget yeah your salvage budget
yeah so that is actually designed to
link into the other mechanics so
basically
um you know if you have an unlimited
budget there's there's sort of nothing
to optimize and the idea here is that
the phantom brigade doesn't have much
time to be on site you know you're in an
enemy war zone it's hostile
they're going to come get you if you
take too long and it is an approximation
for how difficult it is to get the
salvage so if you trash apart like
cutting it off a wrecked mech it's going
to take you a lot longer so you're
actually incentivized to do things like
flank the enemy knock out the pilot get
them to eject and then you're able to
salvage these things much faster so it's
an incentive to kind of get the player
to interact in the game in more
interesting ways
we could of course adjust those budgets
and we probably will have campaign
options for people to change those
things if we want but
one of our goals
of early access is to
find
sort of
the optimal play experience for the
largest number of players and then
one where once we've found that we can
kind of expose a lot of the knobs and
the dials that we use to customize the
experience to let either modders or
players adjust the campaign to
how they see fit but if we were to do
that ahead of time during the early
access period then if somebody gives us
feedback it's like okay well are they
playing with you know this difficulty
level or that difficulty level have they
changed something about one of the dials
that we can't kind of take into
consideration now um so that that's why
it's there is to give
players an incentive to engage with
mechanics more more fully and it's also
thematically appropriate
so just to clarify you're saying like in
a way it's kind of like enforcing the
lore of phantom brigade it's like you
know they they they're not they don't
have armies and armies they they're kind
of like
you know
structured strike teams where they
strike fast take what they can and then
move on before they're there because
most of the time you're in other
people's
other people's uh you know regions
you're not in friendly regions a lot
you're in every other region known to
man and i you know coming back to where
you brought up the early access you know
i've seen a lot of early access games
through the years and i've always been
curious like when it comes to early
access how
accessible it is to be able because to
me early access makes sense when you're
building games like phantom brigade uh
you know these other types of games like
this it's a lot easier to go into that
model to where you can
build with the community build with the
feedback because a lot of the times when
you know let's say that you guys didn't
go the early acts this way you know you
guys made the whole game then released
it there were certain sections of the
game that you know your player base
wouldn't exactly was ideal to but
because you're building with the
community you kind of you know mold the
game to what everyone wants within
reason obviously you can't please
everybody so uh what the question i want
to ask is like how
how was what i'm looking for
beneficial has something like the
preview program uh been for phantom
brigade
i think it's been incredibly beneficial
for us because even coming back to let's
say something like salvage from combat
that system went through a lot of
iteration based on the feedback that we
received with the original system when
parts were destroyed they were lost
permanently and then it took time to
salvage based on the amount of parts you
salvaged and you got everything from
whatever was left
and players didn't like the time the
fact that it took time uh the fact that
the parts were destroyed it was a bit
too brutal in certain cases and we got a
lot of feedback on how we communicated
the reasons for those things
and based on the feedback we gradually
adjusted those systems for example
changing the
destructive permanent destruction of
parts into a
feature that could be enabled or
disabled uh by by motors effectively and
potentially something that we will
enable allow players to enable and
disable when the game is released as a
way of tweaking the difficulty of the
game
and same applies for the time it takes
salvage we removed the
time it takes to salvage parts and
instead switched it to that resource
that is based on the location and how
well you performed in combat so the more
you know enemies you defeat the more
loot you can get
so to give you like a really concrete
example here um
previously
we had the base deploy and when the base
was deployed it couldn't move and you
would be stuck on the overworld while
you're salvaging because you know you've
got all your gear out or whatever you're
trying to get this stuff and what we
found is that it left the player sort of
completely vulnerable and you'd get into
this situation where you try to salvage
and a convoy or a base or a patrol would
come along and they'd see you and they'd
attack you and then you're now in
another battle and you still haven't
gotten your loot next thing you know
you've got like a pile of
you know corpses under your feet you're
like just let me salvage these things um
so you know a lot of those things we
found through play testing and even if
we weren't doing early access play
testing is super important so we would
be doing internal testing but i think
the thing that is
unique
to
um early access is that we can put these
things out there and we can have a
dialogue with the community we can chat
with them in the forums
in discord have a conversation and it's
not just like
bringing people into a session
saying thanks for playing you know we
have people who can actually spend
you know eight hours like you put it on
the game and then give us really nice
detailed feedback we've often had users
give us like
essays yeah you know like literally
multiple pages long of
like feedback and it's all been really
good i i think the entire experience has
been
been quite positive and has
shaped the design of the game for quite
a bit
in general just tests our assumptions
about features there's obviously certain
things that we want to achieve with the
design of different features
but ultimately we're making a game for
for the players for them to enjoy the
game and
having their feedback on how they feel
about those features really helps us
dial in on how to both achieve the
things that we are trying to achieve
from design perspective but also make it
in a way that's as enjoyable as possible
for those who will be playing the game
yeah
one thing i am curious is oh i played a
good amount of and you know there is a
lot of different access to when it comes
to
you know different mech parts different
mechs in general has ever been a
conversation where you guys thought
maybe we should bring like a like a void
type of thing like as always where it's
like animal-like mechs in the game
yeah so actually this was one of the
very earliest conversations we had
because
you know in the genre there's crab legs
there's digita there's you know all
kinds of different mech configurations
and what we decided to do with phantom
brigade by having these simultaneous
turns is an extremely high fidelity of
action like we wanted to sort of capture
the essence of the cinematic battles you
got in something like 8th mst where
they're like sliding around a corner
deploying a shield body checking it back
through a building that kind of stuff
and if you think about the amount of
animation like our animation controller
is
like
yeah and the amount of like procedural
and ik we use and rag dolls like
we basically had a choice very early on
we could have gone very broad and then
we need to do specific animation sets
and then for everything that we would
add the cost is multiplied four or five
times or even an order of magnitude and
complexity when going from
um sort of like a
animal with four legs as opposed to
a two-legged humanoid um
so we decided to spend all of our
fidelity in humanoids
because the one thing i think that
people don't always understand when it
comes to game development is that
you know our
resources are limited in terms of our
attention the computer's resources are
limited it's memory it's processing
power all of these things so for
everything that we add there's something
else that we can't
so
phantom brigade's design has always been
intended to be very laser focused and
you know what is the thing that we want
to capture what is the thing that really
truly matters to the experience so as
much as i'd love to have
crab mechs and tajacomas and like all
this kind of great stuff um instead we
focused on having extremely high
fidelity humanoid style animation and
really capturing the essence of like
people piloting those necks
so
oh go ahead
to point out as well with some things
like let's say spider tanks is one thing
that people often bring up uh and we try
to address some of those things for
example we have hydro tanks that sort of
have these pivoting uh threads uh that
allow them to go slightly higher so
there are ways to do those things and we
try to address them where we can but
there's obviously limitations where
everything needs to work with
the let's say the the turn itself is
players can zoom in really up close when
the turn is executing they can also now
replay it and scrub through the timeline
and see the animation go back and forth
in very slow motion
so a lot of it needs to be really high
by deleting as a result it kind of
limits our time quite substantially or
limits our resources there's also one
more aspect to this too because for
every kind of piece of equipment that we
make
you know with the humanoid max it can be
used on the enemies it can be used on
the player it can be used everywhere so
for every ounce of effort we put in to
add a new part you know you can ensure
is able to be used everywhere but if we
had
sort of like
different body styles then there's a
high probability that those parts are
not going to be interchangeable and then
we would have like okay we've added this
part but you can only use it in these
specific circumstances so those become
very very constrained and you know it
may not seem like it but we're actually
a pretty small indie team like our core
team and van brigade's like
five folks i think on average and then
we have sort of external
uh people at byg who work on multiple
projects that help out
um
so yeah it's a little bit different yeah
so far we've been pretty good with
maximizing uh the potential of all the
content that we added to the game
exactly like even with the
the same hybrid tanks that i mentioned
we have turrets that can literally mount
mac weapons in them just to make sure
that we can maximize that those mech
weapons are not just limited to max but
can be utilized on tanks giving them
more reusability more potential
more
variety within combat
and that also feeds into the loot system
because now you can actually use those
on your necks yes yeah so just to
clarify i want to make sure that uh uh
you guys put a lot out there uh
so pretty much when it comes to you know
any type of animal like mex like at
close in development you was like look
uh we want to
focus more on quality over quantity we
want to make sure everything's redefined
uh what we do do and if you keep writing
it out
you know
eventually the quality would suffer so
you guys chose not to do that broad
inspector because i've talked to a few
developers and they said one of the
biggest issues with developing is uh you
know developers have a huge creative
mind and you know they want to keep
adding so sometimes you do have to you
know
you know
not necessarily cup but have direction
and it's like look we can do this
and uh but
what do we sacrifice with so that's
pretty much what it seemed like you guys
said
yeah yeah we jokingly call it here in
the studio scope
bonking because um i think
you know players might be
kind of surprised but us as devs we get
excited about things too and we're like
oh man it'd be super cool to add like
you know spider mechs and all this kind
of stuff and then we have to like stop
ourselves and go no no no no like how
much would that actually entail and then
if we do this what can't we do and then
it's like all right well maybe we should
actually focus on this thing instead so
you know all of these things are very
intentional
decisions where we've we've weighed
these options and decided where to focus
our efforts with with with you know with
what you guys are talking about you know
the more you think about it the more
you kind of realize
once you start going down that rabbit
hole it's going to cause you know a
ripple and a repercussion to multiple
different things
and you know
because you can you could do so much
with it and that's the really cool thing
about
you know the mech type of uh genre of
things
because you know you could you know have
certain abilities you could have certain
things happen i mean you can have like
staff weapons you can have like all
these different things you can bring
into the into this game and it's very
interesting how and i think that it's
very
it's very pinpoint of what
you've put into the game and
as a gamer and a player i would say that
it is really nice to see how you know
you've kind of focused on and zoomed in
on just that
small portion of the mac based world if
you will
and you never know you know in the
future you could add some expansion
packs and put some other stuff in there
but you know
so so there's things like that i just
want to i just wanted to say
congratulations on being able to keep uh
continuing to do that so yeah because i
have a i have a very very limited
attention span if you can keep me on
your game for more than 20 minutes you
have you have achieved greatness
that is true
one thing i do want to you know focus on
when it comes to this is
you know
i did notice
with the the section you guys went to
gameplay where everybody goes at the
same time you know we were talking a
little bit before the podcast and you
know that not necessarily might not be
an original thought because you said
there's a lot of other games that do it
implement it but i do feel like when i
look at it it's original to me because
uh i feel like you guys did it very well
uh you know the when you have like the
time bar at the bottom left that you can
uh go into exactly you know everyone's
got like the the white interface that
shows where they would shoot then you
after they're in that white you shoot it
and it shows you percentage like i feel
like you guys have implemented a lot of
stuff that's in games like xcom
phoenix point you know uh mech assault
stuff like that but you guys have fine
tone it that makes it work for you so my
question to you guys is
who
what was the thought process when this
system this everyone goes at the same
time system was uh you know thought of
uh did was it something that you guys
you know inspired from another game like
you guys were mentioning earlier or is
it something that like you guys always
wanted to do from the start because of
how it went down
so
you know going from i guess my design
philosophy i try to figure out what the
core fantasy is and
for me it was always kind of directing
your own mech anime in some ways of
actually being able to get these cool
cinematic moments i would see in mech
anime and how to bring them to life on
screen i remember specifically you know
front mission
would have these amazing cutscenes of
the mechs battling it out and sliding
across the pavement and into buildings
and all this kind of stuff
and then when you got into actual combat
it was much more traditional turn-based
you know they'd sit there they plant
their feet they'd shoot take some damage
and just kind of trade
blows back and forth and that's that's
very different i think from
how it feels to watch like a mech anime
where there's all this chaos and
buildings are crumbling all of these
things happening in sort of
continuous smooth time
um
i didn't want to go full real time
because i like the ability to plan and
to think and to reason about it so
that's why we originally
decided to go with the turn-based
platform but fan brigade was originally
traditional turn-based which was you go
i go
so the mec would take an action the
enemy would take an action back and
forth we had like action points it was
much more
old school but the
the kind of impedance to go towards
simultaneous turns came from
tabletop gaming because you know when
you're playing like warhammer or all of
this you know you move all of your units
kind of at once and then resolve things
instead of having to just move
incrementally anatomically
um
so we did originally build the game
completely turn-based
and we found that it wasn't
creating the moments that we wanted it
didn't have that kind of like
physicality and impact
um you know it felt like these little
micro moments and
also
we wanted to do this story of underdogs
in that you're this small team against
overwhelming odds like a really classic
anime kind of story right because in all
these mech anime it's always
you know something special about the
protagonist against you know a horde of
enemies or they're you know the one
group of people who's
turning the tide of the war that's like
part of the the fantasy for for mecca
anime and what we found is that you know
as soon as we added more units
it just drug it out and it felt less
fair because
you know you take a turn and then the
enemy gets like three turns because
they've got three times as many units
and um if you've played like battle tech
or some other turn-based games
especially late game
you know it can be kind of frustrating
because
you know you take your turn and then you
wait several minutes before you get to
do anything because everybody's
scurrying around the map and all this
stuff is playing out sequentially
um so we were trying to find ways of
fixing the pacing and we moved into like
reactions to where enemies could kind of
interrupt your actions and go back and
forth
um and it was this very natural
progression where we kept kind of
slicing time finer and finer and finally
started moving towards this point where
it was like continuous
and then we started running into
okay like how do we represent actions
how do we want like if i want the mech
to move and shoot and to do these things
simultaneously instead of atomically how
do i decide how to do that and that's
when we got into like this
timeline and video editing interface so
you know i want to
really put into perspective with the the
viewers uh you know what you said seems
complex but simple at the same time
but what i want to know from you guys
and i think you know the viewers should
know something like this
just something that you described in a
couple of sentences an estimation how
long did it take you to actually perfect
in terms of development time
right so we built the first version of
the game over something like two or
three years
and then we completely rebuilt it from
the ground up and redid the combat
entirely
in
a span of about a year
uh and i think the entire project has
been six years because
before it was a brace yourself games
project it was a tetragon marks project
which was a company that i had founded
with some friends
and we were a very small studio with
like only a few people all together
before we merged with race yourself
games became part of their their studio
yeah embrace
yourself at that point
yeah brace yourself games they they they
were very friendly to us uh at the event
uh petey is there anything that you want
to talk about in terms of that topic
yeah there was one thing um when you
when you
created this timeline um how long did
you
how long did it take you to realize
of the
the future of like you know the um
um not it's not called over cooking um
when you
know overheat
when you then making for overheating and
things like that
when you when did you realize that that
you know type of um
the type of like game element was going
to be added
probably when they probably when they
were destroyed the other team was like
okay this is broke and we need stuff to
balance exactly right right um so what
we very quickly ran into was that
the optimal play was to fill up your
timeline a hundred percent which meant
that like what what should you do okay
well you should fire every single second
and then
never stop but that's not very fun and
that's not an interesting decision and
it also isn't really in keeping with the
fantasy of
you know popping out behind a building
timing your shot catching them at the
right moment
all of those things so we started
looking at ways of kind of letting the
player pace and reloading didn't really
fit that because you could still fire
like five and then you just reloaded and
then you kind of emptied your magazine
and reloaded there really wasn't much
interest there
so we kind of gradually worked on like
okay well how do we
sort of
make the player sort of space things out
and make the timing of the shots
actually matter so that's why he came
into the game as a mechanic was a way of
you know getting you to actually have a
meaningful decision to make about when
you fired and you could fire really
close together but that also meant that
you were vulnerable for a longer period
of time so it became like interesting
decisions interesting trade-offs
uh and that that literally
went through so many iterations some of
those public some of those not because
we originally had like a system where
the mech would automatically shut down
and then your mech was kind of
vulnerable because they couldn't move
but that was way too punishing because
movement is the life of your phantom
brigade right and
also the issue was that they were just
sitting there it wasn't something for
players they couldn't do really working
you know honestly feel like with some of
the mechanics that you guys uh
restructured because it would be too
difficult
i would consider doing like a hardcore
mode where you re-imply those things or
it's like look that bass is out man you
might get a little bit more you might
heal quicker it's like but they'd be
they're going to be on yeah
i think people might enjoy that if
that's something that you guys could do
in the future
well the thing is is the game is
completely moddable so like all of those
things you could very easily add back
into the game by adding your own actions
and changes in the gameplay behavior um
you can mod most of the stuff in the
game with the text editor yep
quite literally everything every bit of
content that exists in the game is just
a text file like you can go and edit it
with just the game the copy of the game
that you have in a regular text editor
but then it's also i think a lot of
those features that we did disable are
still there just as regular flags that
you can check in the file and it will
re-enable it
um
so and could be reconfigured back to
those settings
yeah
well our kind of our design methodology
is like if it's
basically the same cost for us to just
leave something an option or a toggle
then we do that so for instance we
didn't say
permanently remove
uh the the parts being destroyed
completely that's an option that you can
just check and we can put that behind a
ui and actually have like oh here are
campaign options do you want parts to be
permanently destroyed yes no
um
because right now it just increases
their salvage cost but you can even
adjust the costs and it's completely
configurable
i think a lot of our decisions when it
comes to that stuff was pretty much
focused on making
creating as many interesting
possibilities for players to make cool
decisions when they play the game rather
than things like i just need to manage a
bunch of ammunition now or i just need
to wait uh without doing anything or
it's incredibly punishing for just a
small bit of interesting gameplay it's
kind of trying to move everything into
direction of like
every single
point where players interact with the
game they need to make a choice and that
choice has consequences and there's some
amount of granularity but not too much
where they
go into analysis paralysis so
one thing i want to give my hats off to
you guys is
you guys have successfully
because there's a lot of like
accessibility stuff going on you know
opening games up to as many people as
possible
you know people like
you've seen a lot of times with other
franchises where you know they want to
have more people buy their games so they
they kind of might you know pull scale
some features back just to make it a
little bit more you know easy to certain
degree to uh you know
to get people to try the game what i
like where you guys did is like you kept
the core foundation
at it's true but you was like in order
to make the game more accessible we'll
give you options you know in order to
make the game more accessible uh you
know instead of doing a turn base we
will do kind of a hybrid type of combat
to where if you do want that
action-paced stuff you can get that
because everyone's going to go at the
same time and you're not going to feel
like you know you couldn't do nothing
about this person because you knew
exactly where that person was going and
i had to give that out to you because i
honestly feel like that's not easy to do
especially if you go around and you see
the industry changing as much as it is
i like how you guys found something and
you adapted it and it made it your own
so there's one thing i wanted to clarify
there because when you say accessibility
um that means i think perhaps different
things to us and to you so when i think
about accessibility i'm thinking about
making the game
able to be enjoyed by
as many players as possible when it
comes to
like
support for like color blindness and oh
yeah are we making you like click and
hold and you know actual
accessibility in those regards but um
you know there is another side of it
which is how easy is it for somebody to
get into that's what i was referring to
start enjoying it
and actually that is one of our big
focuses leading up to
our steam launch is
to
kind of smooth out that new player
experience because one of the things
that's happened over early access is
we've added all these cool new mechanics
and cool stuff but it's kind of enabled
at the outset and it's almost a little
bit overwhelming
to just
drop in there um and have everything
kind of uh here's 20 things to manage
where we want to sort of like
gradually introduce the mechanics to you
and let you into the experience a little
bit easier so it's easier to understand
each new thing and then it comes
together to this
um
you know really interesting final result
and there is also the fact that not only
we want players to
have that smooth experience but we want
them to customize the game to
what they want to be enjoying about the
game if players are more into narrative
let's say and we have a lot of narrative
events that lead them on these
journeys through the
like through the their country
we want them to be able to tweak the
game difficulty where they can just
focus on that if they want to and then
the combat will be like a more
interesting thing on the side that they
can experience if they want incredibly
difficult combat and long battles they
can increase the number of mechs that
they bring into combat and we even have
dedicated ui scaling for that to make
sure that if the game still looks nice
and functions when players change a lot
of those variables in the game
and i think it does
that's what i was
i'm sorry
i think that's what i was highlighting
um is
you guys and because i've i've seen all
franchises i love you know they kind of
go away from what made their game unique
and try to like broaden it with you know
turn based action turn base or you know
try try to do as much as they can to
make the genre more appealing maybe i
should have chose my words a little bit
different what i like for you guys is
you guys gave more options instead of
doing that like i feel like you know
because i've been keeping up with the
game for a little bit i i do feel like
you guys have always said this is the
game and we're going to broaden it to
make it more appealing to other people
i think it's by the nature of how small
the team is and how limited our
resources are i to some extent there is
a lot of conscious decision making about
how we
approach different features when we
decide what to add
but there is a very strong limitation of
how much we can add within the limited
time frame so we really need to pick our
battles when it comes to those things
and fundamentally if we already try the
feature and it's interesting but maybe
not necessarily what
we see as the core
as part of a core feature set for
an average player
might we might as well add it as an
option because the functionality is
already there and somebody potentially
can enjoy it and it gives more
flexibility for modders to tinker with
those systems and combine them in
interesting ways
well there's one point i want to bring
up here is that when it comes to design
there is a lot of different goals and
also styles of design and specifically
speaking um
there are designers who have a very
specific experience in mind and they
they really want the player to
experience it you know like oh when they
come over this this rise i want them to
see the sunset and everything is going
to be just so um the kind of design that
i i am partial to is more along the
lines of
you know letting players make their own
fun i i want it to be almost like a
mecca toy box or sandbox for you to have
fun in and all of these premises and
things that we're doing is like good
reasons and justifications to make
you do cool stuff with mechs and to have
explosions and fun and blow things up
and just like
you know it's almost like a toy box um
so that's kind of how i approach the
design and with that mindset you know
why not have it your way why not make it
customizable it is a single player game
uh so we're not really
under those same constraints of trying
to make sure that there's like
you know one very specific
experience i think those games are a lot
more replayable too
because it feels like you have more
control over uh what you do because i
noticed like especially with like the
x-com franchise after a few years of it
being out they on like that long
the long war expansion thing where it's
like just a bunch of updates and i feel
like you know that that's something
similar what you guys have done where
you know you guys give them the give the
player more options to how they want to
play not necessarily what type of game
they want to play uh i do want to go
over a little bit of um you know because
we're about to uh play this out uh just
a little bit of feedback from me playing
the game now obviously you guys want to
comment on anything if any of these are
in the development if they're not that's
fine uh i don't want to put you guys on
the spot like that
but i did see
i feel like the pilot system is is
unique and i feel like it's got a lot of
potential yeah is is the pilot system
itself something you guys are going to
look at in the future
that depends what you mean by pilot
system because our
current updates are focused on pilots uh
we're adding pilot cameras and we're
adding a pilot health system
and things like that um
we are hoping to do even more
after we launch on steam um to kind of
enrich pilots
and we're still working out the exact
details of what that's going to be yeah
do you want them to be characters
yeah
i feel like that's definitely something
that you guys could really uh you know
expand on uh something like you see on
titanfall where there is like a
relationship between the pilot and the
mech you know what i'm saying like maybe
the pilot has like certain perks or
something like i feel like if you guys
are able to in the future to like really
give the pilots you know
maybe not even necessarily i would say
like you look at a something like diablo
obviously completely different i'm just
let me finish before you judge okay like
when you do a loot system or something
where it's like you got commons
uncommons rares legendaries like it
would be cool to see like a system like
that implemented with the the pilots
where you know depending on what pilot
you have you could have a different
outcome if you would have had something
different if that makes sense
it does yeah uh so anything you want to
say about the speedy we right now i do
know that you had to walk away for a
second all right uh we're currently
talking about uh like in like feedback
that you would want to give them oh
feedback i there was there was a couple
of questions i had i don't know if you
guys spoke about them or not
did you talk about um
the like the the pvp were you guys
thinking about ever implementing that
with other people you know being able to
create their own mechs and kind of
figuring out a way that it would be
very similar to term based but at the
same time um you know you you both have
your own uh timelines
that aren't you know that the other
person couldn't see
but more of like um you know
going against another another player
because you know i would love to see you
know like a mech just smack into another
mech and throw them into a building uh
and like you know you're doing that
against another person and something
that they weren't expecting
so
um on that note um one of the other
decisions we made very early on in
development was
whether or not we wanted to approach
multiplayer and we decided against it
because the game is extremely physics
heavy right now
with every bullet being simulated and
everything going on simultaneously and
the building's collapsing and those are
actually very not impossible but that
kind of stuff is very hard to properly
have across the network so we we kind of
made the decision not to do that but
interestingly enough we have dev tools
in the game and one of the ways that we
tested initially before we had ai is we
would just do local
competitive and you can just like use
steam remote play or share your screen
with somebody and then have them plan
the enemy turn and then you plan your
turn and then execute it so you can't
play kind of collaborative like that but
yeah actually doing
networked where it's um you know
synchronizing the data between two
clients and then you're sort of like
that's just outside of the scope of
right okay
actually what would be interesting i
don't know
semantics how hard this would be because
i'm not a developer you guys are doing
it um
it would be cool interesting like you
know how like a madden has a franchise
where someone plays the games and
someone else play obviously there's
times where they play each other but it
would be cool if you can like implement
like a co-op system maybe not a
multiplayer where they're not on the
same battlefield as each other but
they're fighting different battles that
they have to constantly like switch back
and forth between i don't know if that
makes sense that was one of the
questions i've written down so it's
funny that you said that so yeah there
there is some like i don't know i
shouldn't even mention it
oh no don't don't mention that we don't
want to get nothing
to show up is like adelaide is promised
we're gonna have to cut this portion out
she's going to tell us but she's going
to cut it out so yeah yeah yeah
so
edit this out
so
um
when it comes to the
the last little feedback i had is there
clearly is like faction versus faction
you know when you go into these regions
i thought it would be cool if you guys
have like um
like a a rival cinematic going on where
like maybe someone will chase you
through the map that's not really part
of any faction they just don't like you
for some reason like merc like mercy
yeah
like that would be cool
uh you know
i
i just hope the game does really well
i'll leave it at that
yeah
obviously it's like i said like these
are just feedbacks that i have
obviously some of them
one thing i wanted to say is like you
know the the one thing i try to do when
i design games and fender brigades in
particular is
you know
the great thing about it is we can go in
so many directions right like if the
game does really well and people love it
then we can say oh okay cool let's add
mercenaries let's add rivals let's add
these things and i think it all works
very well with the systems um so yeah i
would
love to be able to do those things
someday so we'll see
in general as well to reiterate on a
point where
the game is incredibly modular and it's
credibly multiple so
from our perspective we're obviously
very limited on what we can add within
like we want to add those things but
there is time constraints and resources
that we need to
take into consideration but when the
game
i mean it's out there already but when
it will be also on steam
players can add those things like
modifying which faction controls a
promise a province is pro is effectively
a string or just like a bit of text in
the text files that you can change
and then with some tinkering in the data
you can add a new faction and like
introduce a third faction into the
combat and like
and the systems will sort of take it
from there and
utilize that data in a way that would
allow the combat to play out in a
sensible manner
so
it's kind of
also like
in whichever directions models want to
take it there's
all the opportunities that we think
about when it comes to where the game
can go they can take uh it in those
directions as well based on what they
want the game to become as well and kind
of for building on that
idea of them customizing their
the game for themselves
those there's one other thing that i saw
i was wanted to ask you and think about
and something um
i think like i was saying before about
the the collision mechanics um i think
that they are really really
kind of
unique
because of the way that you have the
physics of you know
one person being able to do one thing
the other thing another person being
able to do another thing
causing this collision
has there been
um talks about or a thought about or is
this something that like we were talking
about before once you go down the rabbit
hole it's a bad idea of doing like some
type of melee
type combat or like a grab like a
grappling type mech that's going to be
able to
push them or move a person or or
something along those lines because
uh
because i was just wondering about that
so
the one thing that we found is that we
added a lot of this physics simulation
and then emergently we noticed players
doing things for example um people would
put their shield up and run into another
mech to knock them down and then we
actually this is a good example of early
access where we said okay players are
doing this let's make this into a
mechanic and now we have like weight
classes and it's very clear who's going
to win those engagements but that's all
based on the underlying physics that we
put into the collision system uh so that
that sort of thing
um
absolutely um
you know aside from that it's hard to
say yeah yeah i thought this thing was
fantastic
sorry all right
so uh my last question is uh now
obviously uh you guys are coming on
steam here but we we console people you
know i got a lot of console friends
there's consoles ever been a discussion
for a fan of brigade stop it petey has
has pc
any kind of discussion or is that
something that you know would depend on
like the success of going to steam uh
you know maybe right
right so
porting a game to console from pc
there's a lot to it um one
is performance and making sure that it
runs you know well and has a good uh
there's like certification there's a lot
of things that we would need to do in
order to get it to run perfectly on
consoles but the other aspect of it is
controller support um so we are hoping
to get the game to support controllers
and then that would allow you to do
things like play it on your sim link or
play it on your couch through your tv or
something along those lines with the pc
mind you um but once we've sort of
squared away those things then it's just
a matter of you know does it make sense
for us to put the time and effort into
bringing it onto a console because there
is
you know a significant cost associated
with that process for each console that
we would want to deploy it on
and that that becomes more of a kind of
like a business decision get right down
to it and that that's
above my grade so you know yeah i'm just
trying to make it the best game possible
and yeah and i did design it to be able
to be played with the controller so you
can read into that whatever you wish
yeah it's like i said i knew if i didn't
ask that the comment section would be
like what about xbox what about
playstation so yeah i'm gonna nip that
it would be great but we'll see so we're
gonna go ahead and uh you know wrap this
up uh first off i want to appreciate
both you for coming on uh i know you
guys are busy people uh you know i
really like your game and i think the
reason that
i'm passionate about that type of
gameplay it goes back to all the way to
like uh final fantasy tactics and then
slowly like xcom and like that grid
space type of rpgs uh turn-based games
in general i feel like the reason it's
like i said yours is unique and i i've
seen throughout the years people i
wouldn't want to say coffee because you
can't really copy mechanics like that's
just how it is it's a mechanic
i feel like very few people take
something that someone else has done or
you know or a turn-based type of game
and make it unique and that's why i like
about your guys's game uh but you know
uh petey any final words you want to say
uh to our guests to you no i just wanted
to say thank you so much for taking the
time to do to come spend some time to
talk to us about you know
uh phantom brigade and i coming from a
person who you know like i said before
is a fan i'm a fan of the game i'm a fan
of you know what work you're doing and
and where you are going with it and i
would say you know i i love what you
guys are doing and fantastic job and
thank you so much for you know making a
game that i i didn't even think of was
possible and then seeing it come to you
know come to my hands and then loving it
so i wanted to say thank you so much for
that
yeah
thank you as well thank you for your
words and your support and taking your
time to help us promote the game it's
really appreciated yeah and you know
feel free to plug any social media
aspects that you guys have uh i know
some people are a little bit more
i don't want my social media out there
like if you have a twitter or something
you want to uh promote
i guess there's the brace yourself games
twitter and the phantom okay twitter
yeah okay yeah
i don't know nothing personal to promote
okay uh so you know once again i wanna
appreciate you guys coming on uh we're
gonna go ahead and uh in the in the show
and